are you doing you [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's me ryan right and I'm Brianna white
Rihanna yeah come on come on do it come
on say it say it [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay we're gonna do a 1up box unboxing
video today with the theme being galaxy
this month so brianna is my co-host
today she will be presenting the items
you always got to get a hot girl to
present items that's the way sorry
importance the American Way right there
all right here you go Brianna started
make sure you save the t-shirt the last
okay first item yes oh yeah I can't do
it you know he does it well Tyrone
Magnus hmm can't do it I suck I suck I
can't even try but look how cute he is
he's so adorable oh no I have a little
Chewbacca we saw a strong good
presenting good presenting good
presenting ah you got Star Trek and Star
Wars Star Wars yeah oh so I could wear
this around my neck and you guys see
that I don't think you guys can see that
a space lanyard obviously Landon I suck
at focusing the camera on this [ __ ] so
I'm sorry guys I'm trying to get you to
see it hmm what are some of the
characters there you clearly have you
got Darth Leia smoker they put smoke in
the middle of it and remove hand between
Liotta yeah Yoda there's the rest of spa
yeah Chewbacca Lukic captain Kurt the
enterprise let's do it what it's a
lightsaber it's a blow-up light saver oh
that's pretty [ __ ] cool
that's really cool where do you find it
floaty yeah I don't like on the base
there this thing yeah by the base we go
it got wrecked hey Brianna haha nice to
meet you [ __ ] saber oh yeah it's really
happy about that's cool app in app in as
always of Wally 1up box Wally okay i'm
gonna try to just back out so you can
see it a little bit i don't know if you
can unload again there you go right
there any there you go Nick items here
huh sweet recognize that guy Rocket
Raccoon it's a cool tack that's a cool
sticker captain Kirby that's cute that's
really cute cuz it's like Captain Kirk
but it's Kirby huh Kirby so fat her be
really you know Kirby's whole body looks
like remember in Return of the Jedi when
they reveal Darth Vader's real face
Kirby's whole shape looks like the shape
of Darth Vader's head that's awful it's
so mean come on no was expecting Darth
Vader to be a [ __ ] I wake up he's like a
bubble from bubble gum whatever q yeah
he's killed but he also looks like you
can't get Skywalker in the future all
right okay you ready for the big the big
piece de resistance the shirt yeah all
right thanks America I'll show the
camera first Shh see that all right now
we're gonna lengthy Oh Hugh oh I'm gonna
rock this shirt tonight
like this sure I go to Star Wars hold on
I gotta change sometimes I'm confident
and like [ __ ] it I'm fat but I'm gonna
take off my shirt right now
self-conscious okay I'll be back for
give you entertain the camera b boy
hello Joe can't told you can't what is
this improv glass make a [ __ ] oh sorry
you're just you already told that story
yeah it's like you can't stop telling
that story sorry on this show before oh
my gosh sweet amazing it looks good on
me hell yeah thumbnail time
alright guys that's the one up these
years this is a really impressive theme
they have this yes I love this it's like
Star Wars but also Christmas it's like
it was amazing yeah I mean obviously
market around the time of Star Wars
known are smart and you know what these
are like fun toys that you really do
want to keep like sometimes I get toys
and I'm like I want to give this away
but these are twins I really want to
hold on to I really want to belong to
this if you get it just a little bit
more solid it could be the next toy that
Veronica and I use but it's just too you
know cuz when she uses on me I want it
to be extra hard this could kill someone
if you put it right about that okay
listen guys you could get a 1up box
there's a description link that exists
on all YouTube videos and in the
description link there is a referral
link to get a 1up box make sure you buy
it through the referral link make sure
don't just go to the website anyway guys
listen if you're new to the Chanel you
can subscribe today by clicking this
button that Briana doesn't think is as
cool as it should be and you could check
up Rihanna White's gaming channel where
she plays video games game a girl check
it out yeah I don't call me that do you
don't like me call the game record
negative connotation really on that I
don't even want to hear it okay so I
shouldn't get you the shirt that says
gamer girl definitely don't it's a good
thing i did not get you a Christmas
present that would have been
embarrassing yeah they would have liked
that and I don't know all the negative
connotations well it's a huge
controversy Wow more like a controversy
kinda yeah yeah